[Music]
there is important new research
providing strong evidence to dispel a
common threat of misinformation about
the covet vaccine a study found there is
in fact no correlation repeat no
correlation between vaccinations and the
ability to get pregnant nikki batis
visited a hospital in chicago where they
are seeing the downsides of being
pregnant and not protecting yourself
from
how worried were you that you would die
i didn't think i would make it out
seven months pregnant and unvaccinated
cantris ana dumaca was lying in an icu
hospital bed wearing an oxygen mask and
fighting for her and her baby's life my
body was literally convulsing trying to
breathe her lungs were severely damaged
by covid she couldn't breathe talk or
walk i wanted my body to carry my son
into this earth and that was it kintree
says she didn't get vaccinated because
she was concerned about her unborn
baby's safety and her future fertility
it's something she regrets this part
gets me a little emotional i felt
irresponsible
because
i put me and my baby at risk currently
around 66 percent of pregnant people
nationwide are vaccinated dr emily
miller is the chief of obstetrics at
northwestern memorial hospital in
chicago
what is the biggest misconception you're
hearing from pregnant patients about the
covet vaccine this fear that the vaccine
is going to cause some adverse pregnancy
outcome and again i think it's really
important to frame that against what the
risk of getting this virus and getting
severe covidina's in pregnancy and that
risk is just so markedly higher a recent
study out of scotland found the
unvaccinated make up more than 90
percent of pregnant people hospitalized
from covid complications and are at much
higher risk of severe complications like
premature birth stillbirth or neonatal
death which occurs when a baby is less
than a month old i was terrified i was
terrified i was crying at nine months
pregnant health care worker danielle
williams contracted kovid but she's
vaccinated her symptoms were mild and
three weeks ago while covid positive she
gave birth to a healthy baby boy do you
think because you were vaccinated and
boosted that kept you out of the
hospital out of the icu absolutely i
absolutely think that as for cantris she
had to deliver her baby boy a month
early because doctors were concerned
about her oxygen levels
now seven months old cj is healthy and
mother and son were able to reunite with
dr miller the doctor who helped save
their lives your mama is a fighter
kentrisse says dr miller's kindness
helped her pull through she is now an
advocate for vaccination kovit doesn't
care about your age your ethnicity your
gender
you pregnant you're not pregnant it
doesn't care
it can knock at your door and take you
out and for any woman that is pregnant
what i would say to them is give you and
your baby a fighting chance
kentrice did end up getting a coveted
vaccine in the hospital before she gave
birth dr miller told us it's unclear if
her lungs will ever fully recover
experts recommend pregnant people
receive a vaccine booster following the
completion of their initial doses and i
want you i want to mention a new study
from weill cornell hospital here in new
york that shows if a person is
vaccinated during pregnancy in any
trimester antibodies pass on to the
fetus that's new science we've come a
long way yeah i was going to mention
that katie made that calculation during
pregnancy with eloise and and we never
regretted it and this is important
because that was a narrative when we
started talking about vaccinations and
women were concerned about the inability
to get pregnant but something she said
was powerful she said i felt
irresponsible because i put my baby at
risk yeah and it's you know there's so
many concerns when you're pregnant
you're told not to do x y and z and then
add a vaccine but we're so so much
further along and theresa's condition
was so bad doctors actually asked her
husband who should we save your wife or
your baby i'm so glad though that she's
telling her story kirby waited until
after the baby was formed to have her
vaccine because she was afraid too
there's so much misinformation but you
hear a story like catrice's who said
kova doesn't care who you are this is a
valuable stick with me yeah the benefits
are there yes yes thank you that's great
information
[Music]